[Musique]
à 15 kilomètres de marrakech où l'aide
mais ça ouvre un village traditionnel
marocain avec ses maisons basses et sa
mosquée
la casbah l'ancien fort du village a été
transformée il y a cinq ans en hôtel
et aujourd'hui il a été réservée pour un
groupe de touristes français
le décor est sublime mais ces touristes
ne sont pas là seulement pour bronzer et
profiter de la piscine
tous sont venus pour un événement
exceptionnel
aujourd'hui céline se marie
[Musique]
cette jeune toulousaine de 33 ans a
choisi le maroc pour organiser un
mariage mémorable
[Musique]
c'est le grand jour
c'est le stress comment comment vous
vous sentez j'aime pas ça en crète après
da je me semble elle aussi
la cérémonie va bientôt commencer c'est
au tour du père de découvrir sa fille en
robe de mariée
c'est bien après
comment votre petite famille magnifique
magnifique c'est assez ban de la voir et
tout petit c'est bizarre comme c'est un
terrain un père au bord des larmes
une mariée très ému que ce soit en
france ou au maroc
le scénario d'un mariage est toujours le
même
céline et son fiancé didier un
toulousain d'origine guadeloupéenne sont
tombés sous le charme de marrakech lors
de leurs dernières vacances nous attend
là-bas
vous voulez un mariage sur le soleil
didier et antilles et on aurait voulu au
départ de faire ressentir puis c'était
un petit peu plus compliqué donc on
s'est tourné vers le maghreb et puis on
a trouvé puis un mélange des cultures
le pays est très accueillant les gens
sont très accueillants
aujourd'hui se marier au maroc est
devenu tendance de plus en plus de
français dans l aventure
il ya d'abord eu des célébrités comme
les chanteurs marc lavoine et axelle red
il ya quelques années et plus récemment
le footballeur nicolas anelka
[Musique]
ose être venu dans cette église pour que
le seigneur confirme lui même par sa
grâce votre décision de contracter
mariage en présence
alors certains en ont fait une
spécialité pour organiser leur mariage
didier céline ont fait appel à l'homme
en chemise rayée au fond de l'église
mourad le responsable d'une agence de
tourisme veux tu être ma femme oui je le
veux
et toi didier pouvais-tu être mon mari
oui je le veux
un mariage catholique à l'église avec
tout le cérémonial un peu en retrait
mourad un oeil sur tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mariage des français comme ça à
marrakech c'est non bah écoutez il ya
quelques années oui mais maintenant
c'est très en vogue se marier à
marrakech est très branché résultat le
planning de monsieur le curé est de plus
en plus remplie à les dommages à jamais
un autre d'un styliste français voilà
qui se marient ici en avril j'avais
aussi un autre joueur portugais attend
donc il ya aussi des célébrités qui est
qui qui choisissent de se marier ici les
amis et la famille vont rester quelques
jours à marrakech
mais il ne débourseront pas un centime
c'est céline et didier qui les invite
une fête de quatre jours pour 30
personnes
cela va leur coûter 22 mille euros et
vous allez voir qu'à ce prix là ils vont
en avoir pour leur argent
une heure plus tard le quart des mariés
arrivent à la casbah où doit avoir lieu
la fête c'est la vie commence
non
[Musique]
ses dromadaires des groupes folkloriques
des musiciens l'accueil est
spectaculaire
il faut dire que mourad leur a promis un
mariage inoubliable
[Musique]
la fête va se dérouler dans une tente
berbère dressée spécialement pour
l'occasion en bas de l'hôtel
il y a
c'est là que mourad à réserver de
nouvelles surprises à ses clients
[Musique]
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
l'ambiance mille et une nuits mourad le
sait c'est ce que recherche la plupart
des touristes au maroc ne savaient pas
qu'ils tour
non
et pour eux c'est superbe
lorsque rémois bhoutan mais plaisir
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'ambiance monte pour mort à tout va
bien sur le mariage des touristes il
fait une marge nette de 30 % soit plus
de 3500 euros dans sa poche
et avec un peu de chance les mariés
leurs commandes auront à d'autres
touristes il voulait une fête
inoubliable
le contrat est rempli qui croire on y
est en fait c'est parfait
mourad doit organiser quatre autres
mariages comme celui ci avant la fin de
l'année au maroc
la demande ne cesse de progresser
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'engouement pour le maroc
n'a jamais été aussi grand à deux heures
et demie d'avion de paris c'est la
destination préférée des français
l'année dernière ils étaient près d'un
million cinq cent mille à y passer des
vacances des randonnées traditionnelle
dans le désert
[Musique]
vous faites jet set de marrakech nous
allons vous montrer des différents
visages d'un pays en pleine mutation
[Musique]
l'objectif du gouvernement marocain est
de quasiment doubler le nombre de
touristes en moins de trois ans alors en
bord de mer ce sont des villes entières
qui sortent de terre où le pays est en
proie à une fièvre immobilière
villa de luxe dans la palmeraie de
marrakech houria traditionnelle dans la
ville impériale de fès peut encore
trouver de bonnes affaires au maroc qui
profitent de ce boom immobilier et
quelles sont les nouvelles destinations
à la mode
[Musique]
place jamaâ lafna le coeur historique de
marrakech
voilà l'image que la plupart des
touristes garderont de cette ville
des joueurs de flûte
[Musique]
des charmeurs de serpents
ou encore des danseurs traditionnels
[Musique]
et naturellement l'incontournable détour
par le sou de marrakech
ils sont des milliers à parcourir chaque
jour des kilomètres de rues elle remplit
des shops
ici les touristes peuvent s'adonner au
sport national
le marchandage
[Musique]
et à ce jeu là les français ont une
fâcheuse réputation
160 à 965 france de macramé maxi et elle
va aller encore el alaoui son discours
des trois comme ça ça me dit zaher est
la mère de tous et bon swing 140g ferme
on prie pour vous fans du jeu que j'ai
rien gagné
et quelques euros de gagnés pour 15
minutes de négociations ce sont les
charmes du souk
mais ça c'est la carte postale car
marrakech désormais un autre visage la
ville est devenue une destination les
plus branchés du monde aussi couru que
miami ou ibiza
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
musique techno jolies filles en maillots
piscine géante et alcool à gogo
ce n'est pas saint tropez mais ça y
ressemble nous sommes dans l'un des
établissements les plus à la mode du
maroc
bienvenue à la plage orange ce concept
de club où l'on peut boire du champagne
et dansé toute la journée a été importée
de saint tropez par alain pedretti en
chemisette à carreaux et bermuda les
abords
dès qu'il a ride il a une priorité
bonjour
il fait le tour de la piscine et
embrasse les jolies filles
vous aurez bronze et la scène points vip
c'est réservé aux belles filles et c'est
un coin qui se remplit vers 16h ou que
les gens viennent boire un peu de
champagne et danser et faire la fête
voilà parisienne qui sont venus aussi
pour se faire bronzer pour le week-end
bonne bronzette tension ça chauffe
c'est une plage très sympa il ya du beau
monde et où il ya de la bonne musique et
voilà on peut faire la fête toute la
journée enchaîné le sort mais venir
faire la fête ce n'est pas uniquement ce
qui motive la clientèle pour attirer du
monde
alain pedretti est parti d'un constat
très simple pour les touristes à
marrakech il manquait un petit quelque
chose on arrive en vacances et on ad
c'est très sympa les gens sont
merveilleux marrakech s'est énervé c'est
dommage a pas la mer donc on allait
développer investissions et on a essayé
de traîner avec du sable
donc les gens viennent se reposer là on
est vraiment venu la plage de marrakech
un petit peu quand comme à saint tropez
ou wakan gens vont à la plage et proches
lors je m'en vais essayer à déjeuner à
ce béni pour ya pas de mariage il n'y a
pas de marée basse à vannes marée haute
à la plage rouge existe depuis un an et
elle ne désemplit pas plus de 500
personnes chaque jour
elle y attirent une clientèle jeune et
fortuné qui préfèrent délaisser la
tranquillité des piscine de leur hôtel
pour se retrouver ici très tôt
merci ont tourné vers ses produits
simples dimanche il ya plein de monde
trouve pas sa place mais alors du doigt
réservé aux randonneurs de toujours bien
trois jours avant pour créer la plage
rouge alain pedretti a dépensé plus d'un
million deux cent mille euros
il a construit la piscine la plus grande
du maghreb 3200 mètres carrés un lourd
investissement qu'il va très vite
rentabilisé notamment grâce au bar de la
plage où il pratique ici des tarifs très
européen 8 euros le cocktail 80 euros la
bouteille de champagne
si il y à aussi un restaurant qui sert
toute la journée mais ce n'est pas là
qu'il gagne le plus d'argent
car si l'entrée de la plage rouge est
gratuite pour se baigner ce n'est pas
vraiment bon marché obligations de louer
un matelas une serviette premier prix 15
euros
et ça c'est très rentable pour avoir
conduit en août 15 euros ça ne rapporte
qu'un zéro g derrière pas de cacher je
veux dire c'est ça un achat d'achat de
150 euros en début de saison et on loue
tous les jours 115 euros dans le carré
viiip c'est beaucoup plus cher pour un
matelas rouge comme celui ci comptait
300 euros mais à ce prix là où vous
offre le champagne
[Musique]
l'année dernière la plage rouge a
rapporté 500 mille euros de bénéfice net
un business beaucoup plus rentable au
maroc que sur la côte d'azur
c'est impossible sont à 120 personnes se
trahissent il fallait payer 120
personnes au sprint français des charges
est là on s'en sortirait pas du tout est
bon ici la chance qu'on a c'est tourné à
9 fois de saison ça c'est vraiment
important c'est neuf fois que saison 9
fois de plage le prochain oui ça
commence en février ont fini en novembre
et donc ça c'est aussi très important
alain ne compte pas s'arrêter là il rêve
d'implanter les plages rouges dans tout
le royaume du maroc
l'année prochaine il en ouvre une à
tanger
comme alain ils sont des dizaines à
avoir fait fortune en pariant sur
l'explosion touristique de marrakech
pour s'en convaincre il suffit de se
rendre à quelques centaines de mètres
seulement du centre ville la zone
résidentielle la plus chic de marrakech
la palmeraie
sur des milliers d'hectares des palmiers
centenaires
le palmier ici c'est comme la vache en
inde c'est sacré interdit de les couper
même quand ils sont au beau milieu d'une
route
[Musique]
depuis une quinzaine d'années c'est ici
en plein coeur de la palmeraie que la
jet set prend ses quartiers d'hiver
derrière ces portails monumentaux des
stars comme naomi campbell leonardo
dicaprio monica bellucci vivre à l'abri
des regards indiscrets
ces maisons de luxe il y en a parfois à
vendre
vincent benvenuti est agent immobilier à
marrakech depuis presque 10 ans ces
villas il en a quelques-unes dans son
catalogue seulement voilà ces biens sont
rares
la zone est extrêmement convoité les
premières propriétés à la palmeraie ont
été à ce point
c'est un conte à rechercher
[Musique]
vous voyez très recherché puisque en
fait c'est le premier angle de la
palmeraie qui est le plus proche du
centre ville
donc on est vraiment une transition
entre le
ce quartier et la ville qui est juste un
peu de 200 ou 300 mètres et qui est
vraiment
comment la campagne avec une végétation
luxuriante avec beaucoup de choses c'est
un coin très agréable de la palmeraie un
endroit très agréable et vous n'avez
encore rien derrière ce portail en fer
forgé se cache une propriété étonnante
ici on pourrait se croire à miami ou sur
la côte ouest des états unis
le style et design la ville a fait plus
de mille mètres carrés habitables
la maison est vendue meublés et c'est le
grand luxe
à l'intérieur les pièces ne manquent pas
on trouve entre autres deux salles de
massage six chambres avec chacune sa
salle de bain privative plus une suite
de 80 mètres carrés qui donne sur une
grande terrasse avec vue imprenable sur
la piscine
[Musique]
donc vous voyez une très belle piscine
n'est coin de détente pour cette villa
construite sur un état comptait pas
moins de 3 millions d'euros
à quelques mètres de là une autre
propriété encore plus grande mais dans
un style beaucoup plus traditionnelle ce
petit palais de 1500 mètres carrés
habitables
[Musique]
à l'intérieur c'est un riad dans la pure
tradition marocaine et pourtant la
maison est quasiment neuve elle a moins
de 4 ans chaque chambre est une suite le
propriétaire s'est même payé le luxe de
construire un centre de balnéothérapie
avec hammam et jacuzzi
cette maison a coûté 1 million 700 mille
euros à son propriétaire il ya quatre
ans aujourd'hui elles vont 5 millions
d'euros soit presque trois fois plus
si les prix flambent aussi vite c'est
que la demande à marrakech est très
forte
de plus en plus de touristes et
d'investisseurs étrangers souhaitent
acquérir des résidents secondaires et
parmi eux les français ils sont plus de
15 mille à avoir investi à marrakech
un marché juteux pour les promoteurs une
vingtaine de résidences au total composé
de villas d'appartements sont
aujourd'hui en construction mais
investir à marrakech aujourd'hui est ce
une bonne affaire comment et pourquoi
les français se laisse-t-il convaincre
et qu'ils profitent véritablement de ce
boom immobilier
[Applaudissements]
river palme c'est un des derniers gros
programme à être sorti de terre dans la
palmeraie un chantier énorme qui a
mobilisé plus de mille ouvriers
il a fallu mettre les moyens car le
programme doit être terminé au plus tard
en décembre 2007
quand on se promène dans la résidence
les travaux sont déjà bien avancé sur 25
hectares il y aura 50 duplex 200 villas
et une résidence hôtelière
un concept qui se développe au maroc et
qui intéresse de plus en plus les
français
le principe est simple vous achetez un
appartement meublé avec tous les
services d'un grand hôtel
c'est justement ce qui intéresse paul et
laurence un couple de marseillais ils
veulent acheter un appartement pour les
vacances mais aussi pour le mettre en
location
ils sont venus ce week-end spécialement
pour en visiter leurs budgets 180000
euros et pour les appâter le commercial
commence par la visite de l'appartement
témoin alors évidemment ça c'est alors
qu'une chose que toi ça non bon métier
de faire quelque chose
ah oui part au chalet pas l'appartement
oui mais là vous êtes dans un
pratiquement un hôtel qui aura la
parenté d'un cinq étoiles donc il faut
aussi que qu'on en ait un sens et si
vous avez une de leurs fêtes la chambre
principale qui est ici premier argument
de vente
une déco tapas et tous les appartements
de la résidence auront exactement cette
même décoration amis aussi des lcd donc
la chambre phrase oui ça fait ça ça sera
dans le forfait oui ici vous avez une
cuisine qui est entièrement aménagé avec
frigidaire congélateur lave vaisselle
four plaques est haute et apparemment
ces arguments font mouche
je vous plais fait comment c'est très
très raffinées les finitions elles sont
magnifiques
direction le coeur du chantier
même si les travaux sont loin d'être
terminées le commercial doit maintenant
leur faire choisir l'emplacement de
l'appartement
et là il va leur falloir beaucoup plus
d'imagination
ça c'est aussi un deux chambres
évidemment quand j'ai expliqué ici vous
aurez ce qu'on appelle la cuisine
aménagée mais là vous avez la
possibilité de faire un coin repas il
fait 105 m² et il a 18 mètres carrés de
logements
bon évidemment encore en chantier donc
après faut voir ça évidemment plantes et
déjà vous avez une vue vous avez sans
vis-à-vis puisque les villes en fait ce
n'est pas tant l'appartement qu'il vend
mais la vue visite d'un deuxième
appartement sur le toit sur la totale
car le deuxième appartement se trouve au
deuxième étage de la résidence
alors maintenant je ne parle plus je
vous laisse
ben voilà voir le paysage sur la
terrasse de 100 m² effectivement la vue
est imprenable
on distingue les contreforts de l'atlas
et toute la ville de marrakech vous avez
la koutoubia vous avez tous vous avez
une vue panoramique à 360° pratiquement
surtout marrakech le dilemme s'amplifie
du coup paul et laurence ne savent plus
lequel des douze appartements choisir là
vous avez effectivement une grosse
surface habitable sur l'appartement
qu'on a visités avant et si vous avez
une surface moins habitable
mais si vous voulez le qu'ici on voit ce
qu'on appelle un forfait donc la vue
enfin et c'est fait partie du coût donc
là on doit être j'ai plus exactement le
prix en tête mais on doit être sûr du
deux cent dix mille euros à peu près là
on est plus sûr du 225 mille euros et
oui la différence n'est pas énorme
ces trente mille euros de plus que ce
qu'avait prévu initialement pour les
laurence mais ça n'a plus l'air de les
déranger
on va voir avec le financement qui vous
propose est ce que je pense
c'est un mince location à combien j'aime
jouer appartement bon après c'est un
calcul à faire
parce que ton appartement tour en plus
eux voulaient louer facilement mais
c'est vrai que le mais ils ne sont pas
au bout de leurs surprises
en plus du prix de l'appartement il va
falloir rajouter des frais
supplémentaires
donc je vais vous mettre les
disponibilités et pour la décoration par
exemple qui leur avait tant plu c'est
25000 euros de plus et c'est obligatoire
ça va de la cuillère la fourchette au
vert la cafetière enfin tous tous pour
virer la personne qui veut rester 15
jours puisse dire est voilà et puis il
ya aussi les charges très élevé ces
charges peut-être mixé entre 1700 et
2000 dirhams par mois
les miss en euros donc s'il 180 à 200
euros par mois pour les charges mais
pour paul et laurence le point le plus
important est de savoir si un tel
investissement a une chance d'être
rentable pour cela il faut estimer
combien de mois par an ils peuvent
espérer louer leurs appartements et à
quel prix
non mais
retouche pas moi je peux tu nous donner
à titre indicatif
c'est une étude de rentabilité alors
nous avons commandé c'est une grande
première on avait du mal à donc on
appris du très très pessimiste comme ça
les gens seront pas surpris on a pris on
est parti sur un taux de remplissage de
30%
je pense que c'est du plus que
raisonnable on a pris une moyenne de
1500 dirhams de location à la nuitée 150
euros ce type de noms mais je vous dis
c'est pour ça qu'on est partis sur dur
pour vous faire pouvoir faire voir aux
gens ce que ça pouvait donner même en
étant sûr du très paisible si on retire
les charges syndics et les 30% de
commission comprend on est déjà aux
alentours de 7 voire 8 % suivant le type
2 le jour ça vous donne déjà un ovni
hockey 7 ou 8% de rentabilité
à en croire le commercial en une
douzaine d'années
l'appartement sera remboursée grâce à
l'argent perçu par la location est
apparemment l'argument semble les
comptes d'un différend sable mais c'est
beaucoup plus cher
[Musique]
je disais c'est un coup de coeur c'est
plus voilà on est venu d'un appartement
de type t2 t3
on allait en profiter trois à quatre
semaines à l'année et surtout faire de
la spéculation
et là c'est un coup de coeur quoi c'est
quelque chose qui ne va plus
nous plaît presse que ses intérêts la
différence tout à fait une semaine plus
tard paul et laurence ont signé l'acte
de vente de l'appartement du premier
étage le moins cher ils l'ont payé 2 121
mille euros tout compris en deux ans
seulement 95 % des villas et des
appartements de ridder palm ont été
vendus à l'origine de ce projet rachid
ria ti un des plus gros promoteurs du
maroc
c'est l'homme à la casquette blanche et
lunettes noires de les refaire mais il
faut les comptes est d'accord
aujourd'hui il a convoqué tous les
responsables du chantier architectes
ingénieurs et contremaîtres il doit
passer en revue la première villa prêtes
à être livrées
ouais ouais la cuisine un meuble de
cuisine qui se décollent des joints qui
manque aux portes
le joie le joint exemple ou encore un
cash oublié sur une prise électrique
certains responsables passer un mauvais
quart d'heure
moi je me dis oh là là un truc qui
moquent citadins et n'est pas elle n'est
pas attention la peinture à ses
actionnaires
à reprendre des petits défauts qu'il va
falloir corriger très vite c'est sa
maison là qu'on vient de voir
elle doit être réceptionné la semaine
prochaine m me beauchamp vous engagez à
la réception pour mercredi prochain dans
les rangs
l'ambiance est un petit peton du modèle
à bas je suis content ce qu'il faut
c'est que à la fin maître du prochain
que je sois content d'accord faut
toujours demander plus jour sa mère
la visite continue et rachid rieti est
très fier de nous montrer le petit plus
de sa résidence
l'accroché de saf
ça donne envie de se baigner
alors ça c'est les lagons artificiel
c'est c'est justement l'âme de ce projet
d lagon bleu turquoise c'est l'argument
de vente
c'est ce que l'on donne à voir aux
touristes
en revanche ce que l'on ne voit pas se
trouve juste derrière ce
[Musique]
un mur construit il y a deux mois par le
promoteur immobilier
il est destiné
à cacher un bidonville et ses 250
habitants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est comme si en parquet en emprisonner
les gens cela fait deux mois que le mur
est construit on peut plus se déplacer
ce mur qui les cachent aux regards
extérieurs hassan doit le longer chaque
jour lorsqu'il va chercher de l'eau pour
les habitants du bidonville
car alors qu'à quelques mètres de là on
remplit d'eau des piscines et des lagons
ici il n'ya qu'un seul robinet pour tout
le village et c'est avec fatalité
khassan observe l'écart qui existe entre
ces deux mondes les gens ils ont de
l'argent
on n'a pas obligé de faire ça moi chacun
sa place je leur a donné ça et john
mensah
c'est comme ça mais d'autres dans le
bidonville supporte beaucoup plus mal la
présence du mur ce serait bien si on
pouvait trouver un autre endroit pour
vivre
à marrakech aujourd'hui un tiers de la
population vit dans des bidonvilles
comme celui ci à terme il est prévu de
les détruire et de reloger leurs
habitants dans des quartiers neufs très
loin des zones touristes car la
spéculation immobilière n'est pas près
de s'arrêter
grâce à river palme rachida dati a déjà
encaissé un bénéfice net de près de 20
millions d'euros
et il ne compte pas en rester là cet
après midi il a un rendez vous important
qui pourrait lui permettre de réaliser
une nouvelle opération immobilière dans
la palmeraie le rendez vous a lieu sur
le bord de la route avec l'homme au
tee-shirt rose c'est un apporteur
d'affaires il fait l'intermédiaire entre
les propriétaires et les promoteurs
immobiliers
pour chaque transaction ce monsieur
reçoit 2 % du prix total de la vente des
métiers qui marche
et justement il a un bien qui pourrait
intéresser notre promoteur un terrain de
44 hectares idéalement situé en plein
coeur de la palmeraie il y a cinq ans
c'était un coûtait 5 euros du mètre
carré
aujourd'hui ils sont dix fois plus cher
jeu des courants l'instant caveau est à
peine arrivé le promoteur a déjà repéré
le potentiel de la zone
vous voyez la magie de ce terrain là on
essaie de venir
j'aurais bien un programme touristique
ici visible non non pas du tout sacré je
voudrais bien une petite densité mais
mais surtout une vie une vie que sa vie
un programme pour le tourisme familial
ça vous convient ici je dirais qu'il y
six et s'il me le propose à 404 en cours
400 dirhams c'est à dire 40 euros le
mètre carré
le mètre carré ça sera une bonne affaire
au niveau le terrain c'est lequel
dans un premier temps rachid riani
s'assure qu'il n'est pas sur un site
protégé et que la municipalité autorise
bien construire ici des complexes
hôteliers
qu'est-ce que ça construit la bad
ça fait dix jours c'est pendant dix
jours que nous et apparemment c'est
lucas bon là c'est quoi des cas c'est sa
note elle donc c'est des complexes
touristiques ici ou là maintenant il
peut commencer à négocier
à combien c'est le prix
4 4 millions de dirhams l'état c'est 40
euros le mètre carré
exactement ce qu'avait prévu le
promoteur juste après il va tout de même
tenter de faire baisser le prix est un
moyen de le toucher pour moi est un
moyen de le toucher pour moi mais le
mans rose rappelle aux promoteurs qui si
les prix s'enflamme très vite
propriétaires à travers le contact va de
200 mille euros
je les vendrais 500 millions en
commettant six mois il était non il m'a
ceux qui lisent les matricules et puis
mais juste à côté là attention combien
tu penses qu'on peut commencer dès que
je ne sais pas il faut on travaille on
avance on avance mais cette fois rachid
rieti est trop gourmand
quelques jours plus tard il aura une
mauvaise surprise un autre promoteur a
proposé 10 euros de plus du mètre carré
et c'est lui qui a fait affaire à
marrakech en cinq ans le prix des
terrains a été multiplié par dix alors
peut-on encore réaliser de bonnes
affaires au maroc
[Musique]
à 300 km de marrakech plus au nord
direction fait
au milieu des montagnes et des oliviers
fais est l'une des quatre villes
impériales du maroc
elle est célèbre pour ses 143 mosquées
ces vieux remparts
la vieille ville la médina a été classée
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
à l'intérieur on re découvre le maroc
traditionnels les ruelles ont préservé
leur authenticité fait aujourd'hui c'est
la destination qui monte auprès des
touristes
le must dormir au coeur de la médina
dans une maison traditionnelle
le riad
[Musique]
olivier monnier 38 ans et militaires
dans deux ans il est à la retraite et il
a décidé de venir s'installer au maroc
il veut investir dans un riad une de ces
maisons traditionnelles
car il y aurait aujourd'hui à fès plus
d'un millier de ryad à vendre les prix
sont très variables
vingt mille euros pour 1 80 mètre carré
trois cent mille euros pour les plus
luxueux
alors est-ce facile d'en acheter un pour
quel prix et dans quel état
c'est ce qu'olivier va découvrir il sait
que l'immobilier est en train de flamber
il veut acheter vite et son temps est
compté
je me donne deux à trois jours pour
retrouver à ce que ce qui m'intéresse et
encore deux à trois jours derrière pour
conclure des affaires
carole à la finalité de de mon séjour
c'est de repartir dit fier en ayant
signé l'équivalent d'un compromis de
vente
histoire de ne pas devoir revenir et ne
pas subir la flambée des prix cinq jours
pour réussir ce pari il a pris rendez
vous avec les agents immobiliers de la
ville comme frédéric cela en chemise
blanche le budget de livier cent mille
euros
mais à ce prix là que va-t-on dû
proposer le premier riyad est au fond de
cette petite ruelle dans la médina
la première surprise c'est ce que la
porte va s'ouvrir un peu à la porte
s'ouvre premier bon signal à l'intérieur
une maison traditionnelle avec balcon
colonnes et patios
première réaction bien c'est bien c'est
grand et du volume mais il y a quand
même un sacré bémol
ici il faut tout refaire oui bah oui
toujours
tout est à restaurer c'est à dire tous
les gens qui viennent chez nous vient
qui viennent chez nous sont obligés
d'avoir un budget de restauration
derrière mon nom ils passent à travers
donc il ya obligatoirement électricité
plomberie assainissement des murs et
incision
olivier n'est pas vraiment emballé un
dernier coup d'oeil sur la terrasse pour
la vue mais elle n'est pas ici qu'il
réalisera son rêve ce qu'il aimerait
c'est son petit palais des mille et une
nuits un peu comme celui ci un jardin
avec piscine qui donne sur une
authentique maison marocaine à
l'intérieur des colonies une fontaine en
marbre au milieu d'un immense patio 8
pièce au rez-de-chaussée et à l'étagé
qui donne sur ce jardin intérieur
les propriétaires de ce rillettes de
1200 m² ce sont eux que pierre marie et
caroline des lyonnais ils ont acheté
avec des amis il y a 6 ans pour une
bouchée de pain
cent mille euros le prix d'une chambre
de bonne à paris tout juste le budget
d'olivier ils ont réalisé deux cent
mille euros travaux et aujourd'hui ils
en ont fait une affaire particulièrement
juteuse je m'entends déjà réservé deux
nuits ils ont des réservations jusqu'au
mois de décembre
le riad est plein 10 mois sur 12 leurs
atouts avoir été parmi les pionniers à
s'installer à fès alors forcément ils
ont été référencées dans la plupart des
guides nous n'ont pas fait grand chose
après vient à l'époque j'avais il ya vu
de la part des électeurs lui il y avait
il est en recherche de rial sur fais
donc comment étaient les familles les
premiers bons
[Musique]
référencés résultat les touristes
viennent du monde entier pour séjourné
dans cet hôtel
pierre marie caroline et leurs associés
se frotte les mains
150 euros en moyenne la chambre par nuit
et du personnel pays à des prix marocain
cette maison d'hôtes est un business
très rentable
la petite entreprise dégage un bénéfice
net de près de 20000 euros par mois
alors forcément ça donne des idées et
olivier aimerait bien se mettre sur ce
même créneau en trois jours olivier da
visité une vingtaine de ryad
il veut lui aussi créé une maison
d'hôtes alors tout l'intéressent l'état
des pièces leur taille ou encore
l'intimité des chambres
non
à chaque visite il prend des photos pour
sa femme
elle me fait confiance mais c'est vrai
quand même bon dans la décision
son avis compte au moins pour la moitié
trois jours de chasse au trésor
olivier venue gâcher une vue digne de ce
nom et le meilleur prix
au bout de trois jours de visite
enfin une bonne surprise il a trouvé un
riad qui lui plaît seulement voilà
question prix il ya un problème alors le
prix et on va dire un petit peu à
discuter pour l'instant il ya un million
cadre de dirhams
ça fait à peu près entre 125 130 mille
euros un petit peu puisque respect que
j'ai pour l'instant on est un petit peu
au dessus de mon budget je discute et on
va voir son pouvoir est négociée au
maroc ce n'est pas une mince affaire
olivier rencontre le propriétaire il ne
parle pas français alors c'est l'adjoint
de l'agent l'homme envers un marocain
qui va mener la négociation avant
explique ans un client très sérieux qui
tous les travaux il ya vraiment beaucoup
de travail à faire
il n'y a pas de décor il ya beaucoup de
frais tu sais tout ça oui je sais c'est
pas décoré oui lui ce que c'est c'est un
client sérieux il à faire quelque chose
de bien
c'est vrai les murs onu nous on est
pauvres la discussion s'enlise alors
olivier prêt à mettre un peu plus que
cent mille euros
son budget de départ moi je suis prêt à
faire une proposition à 120000 euros
s'ils acceptent à signer demain
apparemment il ya trop d'héritiers dans
la sphère salaires au niveau du prix mal
engagée car ici le prix de ce riad ne se
fixe pas au nombre de mètres carrés mais
au nombre d'héritiers il faut qu'avec
l'argent de la vente tous les héritiers
puissent acheter un nouvel appartement
pour que l'intéressé comme un héritier
ouaip me terrifie ses frères sais c'est
que ça fait les frais
huit frères et soeurs se sont donc lui
familles à reloger l'achat du riad se
présente mal alors j'aimerais ça a l'air
mal engagée on va voir va laisser la
nuit pour réfléchir mais je sais pas ça
me paraît c'est vrai que ça fait un gros
budget finalement une fois de plus la
vente ne se fera pas
le propriétaire refuse de baisser le
prix
chaque soir olivier fait ensuite un
rapport à sa femme elle n'a pas pu venir
et s'inquiètent beaucoup de leurs
investissements alors il lui envoie des
photos et répond à toutes ces questions
par mail
c'est le rituel du soir répondre on a
fait aux questions qu'elle a pu se poser
dans la journée as-tu chiffrer les
travaux avec madoff récents manoeuvre le
notaire sait combien un mot qui revient
souvent dans sa bouche quand même c'est
le maureen et fait un peu peur ça allait
un peu peur vraiment que j'achète
quelque chose de complètement délabré
qui le jour on veut s'installer sera
invivable tout va tomber sa femme
s'inquiétait lui n'a toujours rien
trouvé dans trois jours il doit rentrer
en france
alors dès le lendemain matin olivier va
mettre les bouchées doubles
il a rendez vous avec un nouvel agent
immobilier pascal madeleine bah oui je
pense que l'on est reparti pour de
nouvelles aventures
oui un petit peu quand même
les jours passent mais bon pas de stress
cette fois-ci l'agent immobilier lui
aurait trouvé la perle rare
et effectivement olivier tombe sous le
charme
havas moi qui veut de l'espace
apparemment ici j'ai l'impression d'être
servi ouais c'est c'est quasiment ce que
j'ai vu de plus grand depuis que tu es
ici 350 m² un immense passion c'est tout
ce qu'il rêvait là j'en rajoute les
fontaines centre mais là encore le prix
dépasse le budget d'olivier le riad
coûte 120 mille euros mais peu importe
olivier s'y voit déjà il craque pour la
décoration s'enthousiasme pour les
grands volumes là je verrais bien un
salon ici d'yssingeaux marocain pour
voir le thé etc et deux petites chambres
après seulement une demi-heure de visite
olivier décidé c'est celui-là qu'il veut
reste à retrouver tous les héritiers
pour s'assurer du prix mais ça c'est le
travail de l'agent immobilier
olivier lui à une mission plus urgentes
convaincre sa femme de lui donner le feu
vert pour acheter ce riad même si le
prix dépasse le budget qu'ils avaient
prévu merci a lancé moi ouais toi ça va
ouais bah alors on va la journée était
bien superbe
donc ça y est je pense que là on a
trouvé vraiment ce qu'on veut par contre
c'est un tout petit peu plus que le
budget qu'on s'était non mais c'était
on s'était bombe look un peu sur 100000
euros lassé 120000 tous frais compris
mais tu peux me croire ça allez vous
vraiment non non non non il est au
contraire il est je veux dire il ya
quasiment un an mais il ya quasiment que
de la déco à faire et il est oui oui tu
peux oui mais il ya des tables bien sûr
tu peux rentrer dedans
il est bon il y habite à billio nord
marocaine je dirais l'état des toilettes
à dos
non non non non non il est très très
content voilà alors vous l'avez coin du
bois écouter oui j'espère pas de façon
je dirais qu'elle fait elle a une
confiance aveugle à une confiance
aveugle
c'est peut-être un peu vite olivier a
oublié de parler d'un petit détail
alors oui je sais pas faut compter à peu
près vu la taille
je tiendrai 50 60 mille euros non non
non non mais en travaux que en travaux
non mais ça allez vous ça veut dire qu
120000 tu rajoutes
mais non c'est bon ça arrive alors pour
la rassurer olivier sur sa botte secrète
c'est lui qui fera une grande partie des
travaux oui oui bien sûr tu enlèves au
moins où un tiers quoi ouais ouais ouais
voilà aurais-tu voit peu près mais ça il
faut en discuter après oui mais il met
dans l'immédiat il faut acheter le mais
non oui oui on va arriver c'est un peu
de stress ouais c'est un peu le stress
quand même je pense qu'une fois que le
candidat était reposé ses niveaux
qu'est-ce qui fait la première manche
est gagnée
reste à s'entendre avec les vendeurs
lendemain matin olivier a rendez vous
chez le notaire avec l'agent immobilier
pour signer le compromis de vente
ils pensent que c'est une simple
formalité seulement voilà l'affairé est
loin d'être conclue
ça se passe chez la doule la doule c'est
l'équivalent du notaire au maroc qui
s'appuie sur le droit musulman - si
c'est lui qui va procéder à la signature
de l'acte de vente
l'agent immobilier a bien travaillé
en 24 heures il a réussi à réunir les 11
héritier mais là une autre épreuve
attend olivier la famille se retire pour
discuter
tous ne seraient pas d'accord sur le
prix
la colère de la ville
ils sont en train de discuter on discute
jusqu'au bout en fait on n'a pas signé
encore donc il est chaud nature moyen de
récupérer peut-être quelques dirhams en
plus je n'espère pas pour olivier mais
bon donc c'est toujours comme ça ça
arrive souvent que les prix changent
dans votre bureau
les prix wind souvent souvent
olivier ça va est un peu tendue au bout
de 20 minutes la famille revient et vous
ne la verrez pas car ici les histoires
d'argent doivent rester confidentielles
bonne surprise ils se sont finalement
mis d'accord sur le prix et il n'a pas
changé c'est toujours 120000 euros
comme olivier n'a pas encore de compte
au maroc c'est l'agent lui même qui
propose de faire le chèque il doit faire
vite pour ne pas risquer de tout faire
capoter man 2 sort en france et à son
enfance au maroc
moi je vais laisser aujourd'hui un
chèque de caution en leur entier pour
vous pour vous soyez certains que je me
suis achète il ne veut pas non plus
risquer de perdre sa commission de 6000
euros
la famille est d'accord l'agent signe le
chèque le compromis de vente peut enfin
être signées d'abord parler aux
héritiers puis c'est au tour de livres
yann ont dominé un badge attention on a
essayé j'ai signé tout le monde a signé
sa y est apparemment furent compris
yeter l'arrière du maroc fès et
l'impérial il ne lui reste plus qu'à
rénover son riad pour en faire une
maison d'hôtes et espérer que fès
connaissent le même essor que marrakech
[Musique]
pour les voyageurs en quête
d'authenticité
il existe au maroc un tourisme plus
artisanale et traditionnelle qui lui
aussi se développe à grande vitesse
direction le sud est du pays
[Musique]
des massifs rocailleux à perte de vue
des petit village perdu dans les
collines
c'est une des régions les plus pauvres
du marron
ici les habitants vivent d'élevage et de
la culture des dates
mais depuis quelques années les
touristes commencent à arriver
au bout de la route
mamie le dernier village avant le désert
une impression de bout du monde un
village de maisons entièrement
construite en terre la température ici
peut atteindre jusqu'à 55 degrés l'été
depuis quelques années le village s'est
ouvert au tourisme les habitants se sont
mis à organiser des excursions dans le
désert à dos de dromadaire
une démarche au départ très artisanal
aujourd'hui c'est un business dans les
rues demain midi ils sont une dizaine à
avoir ouvert leur petite agence de
voyages tous propose les mêmes services
excursions et bi voile dans le désert en
cas de 4 ou en dromadaire
[Musique]
parmi eux hassan 23 ans
ce fils de nomades a grandi à m'hamid
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et aujourd'hui s'il roule en 4 4 dans
les rues du village
c'est grâce à cette petite boutique qui
l'a ouverte il ya deux ans
son nom bivouac sous les étoiles
c'est aussi le nom de son site internet
pour le créer il s'est fait aider par
daniel une institutrice française à la
retraite installé dans le village on a
beau être aux portes du désert la
boutique est connecté avec le monde
entier et c'est d'ailleurs grâce à un
site internet
khasan attire la majorité de ses clients
le ctd traduit en français en anglais et
on pense le faire aussi en espagne ont
utilisé un site c'est hassan qui a eu
l'idée et c'est moi qui les fais c'est
superbe il faut avec le travail de
tourisme maintenant j comme on dit chez
nous qu'est ce qu'il ya dans le souk
il ya des choses nouveau il faut
rejoindre attend aussi mettre des choses
noté restera toujours à saint vite avec
son temps mais il sait que ce que
recherchent les touristes celle inverse
ceux qui viennent ici à va vite veulent
découvrir le maroc traditionnels ils
recherchent du dépaysement et de
l'authenticité
l'ours kazan reçoit ses clients il ne
les loges pas à l'hôtel à 3 km des
m'hamid il a fait construire un bivouac
en plein désert on à sa tante
on l'appelle en arabe satrem à cela on
longe toute ses clients géologie 30
personnes
là on va voir un exemple
une seule personne un signe et voici la
chambre pour les baroudeurs solitaire
une natte à même le sol
les familles elles ont droit à un petit
confort supplémentaire ça c'est un autre
tente avec 3 5/10 matin un peu confort
et la tante normalement on voyait pas la
toile parce qu'une couverte par un autre
ici ça permettra empêcher des sables qui
pense qu il ya neuf ans l'attend il
passe m'aurait dit ça dans son bivouac
hassan a tout prévu y compris un
restaurant quand il ya trois tables et
quelques tabourets là aussi le confort
est sommaire mais c'est exactement ce
que recherche hassan jeu cei de faire un
peu le confort un petit peu de confort
mais pas très très exagérées jampanoï ni
perdre et je veux laisser un petit pic
et antiques et gardent leur charme
le bivouac vient d'être entièrement
nettoyé quart des clients sont attendues
pour la soirée 18h après cinq heures de
route en provenance de ouarzazate
jean-paul sa femme carole et françoise
une amie du couple arrive enfin à
m'hamid ce n'est pas grâce à internet
mais par le bouche à oreille qui l'ont
découvert bivouac sous les étoiles
[Musique]
à peine arrivé nos vacanciers sont mis
dans l'ambiance avec le traditionnel thé
marocain
après chacun d'eux a payé 120 euros pour
une excursion de trois jours dans le
désert en pension complète à dos de
dromadaire et en 4,4 en données dans
madère et deux deuxièmes joueront leurs
quatre 4 rejoindre vers 3 heures pour
continuer vers les grandes villes
hassan leur a concocté un programme sur
mesure car pour eux l'important c'est de
découvrir le pays autrement de
rencontrer des marocains et de vivre
avec eux parce que même en location
mêlant d'hôtel en hôtel on partage pas
l'avis alors que là le les bivouacs et
tous avec hassan c'est vraiment un
partage à vie la tranquillité c'est le
désert rien à voir avec paris mais ça
par contre ça nous rappelle bien paris
tu vois après avoir éteint son portable
hassan conduit les vacanciers dans leur
appartement en plein désert joli contre
pibrac la géologie 30 et nous serons
nombreux là non ce soir je sois aya que
nous ils ne sont que trois mais pour
s'occuper de ce soir hassan va employer
une dizaine de personnes il l'aura
organiser une authentique soirée berbère
pendant qu'un cuisinier prépare un repas
typique marocain dans la salle du
restaurant nos touristes ont droit à un
concert privé de musique traditionnelle
marocaine
pas moins de cinq musiciens ont rejoint
hassan en réalité ce sont des frères des
cousins ou ami de la famille hasan les
emplois pour accompagner les touristes
tout au long de l'excursion
alors ils seront tour à tour musiciens
cuisinier guide chameliers chauffeur ou
porteur d'eau mais une soirée 100%
authentique ne saurait pas totalement
réussite sans le petit frisson du désert
pourtant cette fois ça ne fait pas
partie du forfait d'hassan une araignée
venimeuse s'est glissée dans le bivouac
et deux sur les chaussures est à
chaussures ah ouais
à 3 0 de noir désir tout à fait tout à
fait
le lendemain matin réveil à l'aube
les quatre dromadaires attendent déjà
leurs clients donc tu es sage aura passé
trente six heures ensemble on était en
droit chaque dromadaires et son guide
coupat hassan 15 euros par jour
c'est ce qui lui coûte le plus cher
[Musique]
comment vous sentez vous non mais mes
pieds en dessous et c'est parti pour
trois jours de randonnée
direction les grandes dunes du sud
marocain
[Musique]
parfait pour la voiture
ah ça ne les accompagne pas il a du
travail qui l'attend en ville
[Musique]
voilà
car aujourd'hui c'est lundi et au
village c'est le souk
le marché traditionnel marocain c'est le
lieu de rencontre des paysans de la
région
c'est ici qu'a c'est une recrue une
partie de ses employés payés à la
journée ou à la tâche comme ce monsieur
aux turbans jaunes
oui c'est le monsieur qu'ils portent de
longues
cédric je fais travailler ça fait
presque trois semaines le vois tu
travailles chapeau je le donne 15 des
reins paris dont il dans la journée
louis et transport qui ramène au moins
huit ou dix à la consigne les 150
dirhams par jour soit près de 15 euros
pour louer c'est un beau journée
s'il vient travailler un jour n'est
entré dans le seau maximo suffit d
efforts ils gagnent 100 variable qui
fait 14 12 ans à ce prix là il n'a pas
beaucoup de mal à trouver de la main
d'oeuvre et fait travailler pour les
toilettes et les douches en filant
restaurants et des attentes
et grâce aux courses qu'il fait pour
nourrir ses clients hassan contribuent à
faire vivre les petits commerçants
mais il s'est fixé des règles de
conduite très précises par exemple dans
cette épicerie
il ne va acheter que les produits de
base là il est en train de vous proposer
mais moi j'ai déjà d ailleurs de
racheter dans un autre c'est le tourisme
équitable version hassan d'ailleurs en
deux ans le jeune homme ne s'est pas
vraiment enrichi mais ces conditions de
vie se sont améliorées vous allez voir
qu'elle reste pourtant modeste il nous
emmener chez lui dans sa famille mais
c'est mon père rentré ça c'est ma mère
et s'occupe toujours de nos dans la
maison avant de monter son agence hassan
et sa famille vivaient ici dans ses murs
en terre mais grâce au tourisme
il avait aménagé trois pièces et a
apporté un petit peu plus de confort
[Musique]
normalement là on a un petit douce une
douche avec l'eau courante
on arrivait puisse acheter un petit
frigidaire qui est dans la cuisine
ça permettrait de garder des choses
longtemps des tomates et des légumes et
des fruits et aussi de garder l'avion un
réfrigérateur qui fait aussi de
pharmacie ça c'est les médicaments là
c'est la cousine
c'est là on prépare pour nous la mer à
manger avant on n'avait pas de cuisine
c'est par terre pour la mer c'est mal au
dos chaque fois de faux médicaments
maintenant il se sent bien ça c'est la
terrasse de la maison quand il fit chou
le soir on dort ici
et enfin sur le toit le seul signe
extérieur de richesse une parabole
selon israël à satan alors louis je peux
dire rire a de la chance
noah l'âge de nuit on n'a pas trop vu le
confort prochain objectif d'hassan
financer l'opération de la cataracte de
son père il espère pouvoir y arriver
avant la fin de l'année en espérant ses
effets l'opération port lay s'ils voient
de leur côté les touristes terminent
leur deuxième journée dans le désert
cette journée dans le déshonneur
excellent excellent et et puis lui est
super gentil là des oreilles magnifique
l'autre derrière il a des pieds superbe
par contre les décembre c'est pas génial
alors vous avez abandonné leur malheur
on abandonnait 2 revers dont mais c'est
merveilleux c'est fabuleux si on l'a l'a
vu la hausse extraordinaire
on est vraiment seulement données
perdues au milieu tout extraordinaire
hassan les rejoint à la tombée de la
nuit
il apporte tout le matériel nécessaire
pour le comblement du soir c'est du luxe
s'est levé qs alors qu'il n'ya pas grand
chose mais c'est celle luxe le luth
c'est aussi de pouvoir savourer un
tajine en plein milieu du désert comme
s'il avait été préparée dans un grand
restaurant
[Musique]
mais lui un salaire sur ce voyage à san
ne gagnera que quelques dizaines d'euros
mais il aura fait vivre directement ou
indirectement une dizaine de villageois
ça n'a l'air de rien mais depuis deux
ans grâce aux excursions en dromadaire
le village de mamita réussi à stopper
l'exode des jeunes vers la ville l'année
dernière m'hamid a pu construire son
premier lycée
[Musique]
pourtant aujourd'hui ce tourisme
artisanal ce n'est pas la priorité du
pays
le gouvernement marocain veut développer
le tourisme de masse le tourisme
balnéaire
[Musique]
il veut exploiter ses côtes et ses
milliers de kilomètres de plage
le royaume a décidé de construire des
stations balnéaires tout au long de son
rivage
[Musique]
six villes entièrement nouvelle qui
sortiront de terre dans les cinq
prochaines années le premier chantier
lancé et au nord du pays sur la côte
méditerranéenne à saïdia
sur cette plage de 15 kilomètres de
sable blanc
l'ensemble du projet a été confiée à
l'un des plus gros promoteur immobilier
espagnol fadesa mais voilà la ville qui
a été imaginé des plages aménagées avec
bar sur pilotis des appartements et des
villas avec piscine entourée de
végétation luxuriante et de terrains de
sport
en tout une ville de 700 hectares
entièrement aménagé il y aura un centre
commercial des restaurants une clinique
privée et un port avec sa marina pouvant
accueillir plus de 800 bateaux un projet
pharaonique mais aujourd'hui on est
encore très loin de ça des maisons
sorties du sable
des carcasses ti meubles en béton
des lotissements au milieu de nulle part
une ville encore fantôme au bord de la
mer un spectacle étonnant ici avant il
n'y avait que du sable et une forêt
[Musique]
les travaux ont commencé il y a deux ans
le chantier mobilise 3000 ouvriers
marocains
si les délais sont tenus la ville
devrait être entièrement terminée en
je
et voici les deux hommes qui ont réalisé
ce projet à droite en blanc l'architecte
marocain qui a dessiné la ville à gauche
en costume sombre juan cano le
responsable du projet envoyé par le
groupe immobilier espagnol fadesa
environnement quand vous voyez ça comme
ça aujourd'hui vous êtes fier puisque
faire mais même eu quand on regarde
trois ans trois enfants et les gens
quand on expliquer tout ça nous regarde
et qu'on descend peu feront ils
croyaient pas légion il ferait pas mais
maintenant on a une demande énorme mais
vous vous y croyez au début oui vous
avez jamais eu de doute non non
franchement moins
saïdia s'avère être une excellente
affaire commerciale pour le promoteur
car pour toutes ces terres ils n'ont
rien payé
elles ont été données par le
gouvernement marocain et aujourd'hui
chaque fois que le groupe espagnol dans
une villa ou un appartement
la totalité de l'argent rentre
directement dans les caisses de fadesa
et c'est sur cet accord que le groupe a
accepté un énorme investissement
pour ce qui concerne fallait nous on est
en train de réaliser
pour les verts d'al gore la marine à
tout ça ces 600 millions d'euros
vous investissez 600 millions d'euros et
vous espérez gagner combien normalement
avec 1
vingt cinq pour ça on a payé comptant
150 millions d'euros de bénéfices mais
peut-être beaucoup plus
[Musique]
car pour l'instant la commercialisation
de saïdia a très bien commencé les
premiers appartements seront livrés à la
fin de l'été
et voici à quoi il ressemble
comptez environ 80000 euros pour un deux
pièces de 56 mètres carrés et 200000
euros pour un duplex 251 mètres carrés
presque toutes été vendues
farid chbani est le directeur commercial
de fadesa et il est optimiste il
commercialise déjà les autres lots
d'appartement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parution cet endroit langues et
combien la barque là on est à peu près
sur 250 appartements total une fois
terminé ses 250 appartements
combien sont vendus là on a vendu 82 80
% +4 1% actuellement à on va dire
majoritairement en anglais espagnol
mais pour farid chbani la tâche est loin
d'être terminée il ya en tout plus de
trois mille appartements à vendre
quant aux villas elles ont presque
toutes déjà trouvé des acquéreurs
[Musique]
jean-jacques fait partie des rares
français qui en ont acheté une
il l'a choisie sur plan et il vient
régulièrement observer l'avancée des
travaux
on approche est ce qu'on va trouver
premières constatations à première vue
la route n'est pas encore terminée bon
au bout du chemin
le lotissement dans lequel se trouve sa
maison à och et un peu de changements
petit peu de changement changement qu'on
a eu un
la dernière fois qu'il est venu c'était
il ya un mois
on espère que ce soit assez rapidement
pourquoi une grosse une grosse avance et
si oui dans les travaux alors maintenant
il faut voir l'intérieur ce qui a été
fait jean-jacques est impatient il
espère pouvoir entrer dans les lieux à
la fin de l'année donc ça c'est la
cuisine avec une petite carrière qui
vivent aux rayures et les ballons d'eau
chaude à l'intérieur peu de surprises
seul le gros oeuvre est terminé et bon
le carrelage la donc mais l'atout
principal ce n'est pas le carrelage
c'est la superficie 280 m² au sol ah oui
c'est une chambre si donc on se bornait
un peu perdu la passion la villa est
livré avec un terrain pour faire un
jardin et sur le toit une grande
terrasse avec vue sur la mer et la
campagne environnante
celle ci vaut je parle en euros 400 6000
euros en france vous doublez carrément
le prix temps si vous avez sur la que la
côte d'azur vous ce que vous pouvez
répéter sûrement
deux à trois fois moins cher qu'une
maison en europe au bord de la mer c'est
l'argument commercial de fadesa pour
inciter les touristes à investir au
maroc
mais ce n'est pas le seul tout a été
prévu pour attirer la clientèle
européenne
il ya d'abord le futur centre commercial
ce sera le plus grand du pays banques
supermarchés restaurants et discothèques
les habitants pourront y trouver tous
les services auxquels ils sont habitués
en europe
[Musique]
et puis il ya le port et sa marine à
creuser dans le sable
[Musique]
il a coûté 90 millions d'euros pour le
promoteur c'est un investissement
indispensable c'est même l'un des
principaux arguments marketing
on
[Musique]
en fait le bassin méditerranéen les
côtes des côtes françaises espagnoles du
bassin méditerranéen sont saturés des
très difficile de trouver une place de
pain bon compte en profite c'est pour ça
que nous sommes positionnés de cette
manière là les prix seront inférieures
de 40% aux tarifs pratiqués dans les
ports européens
tout est bon pour vendre la ville fadesa
a aussi vendu les terrains vierges un
promoteur anglais
à charge pour lui de construire ses
propres villa est de trouver les clients
et ce dernier a eu une idée originale
nous sommes à malaga au sud de l'espagne
simon est directeur commercial de
property logic la société qui vend ses
villas ce matin il a donné rendez-vous
un groupe d'anglais des clients
potentiels
il les a invités à venir visiter le site
de saïdia mais pas n'importe comment en
jet privé
chaque semaine il emmène ainsi des
petits groupes de cinq à dix personnes
en visite vip
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la réserve et de jets cela
coûte aux promoteurs environ 500 euros
par personne
[Musique]
dans l'avion les acheteurs parcours les
brochures publicitaires des magazines
sur papier glacé avec villas somptueuses
et piscine de rêve
[Musique]
pourquoi allez-vous maroc
on a regardé sur internet
on a pensé à notre retraite
à ce qu'on allait faire de notre temps
contre m
on peut passer du temps à l'étranger et
pas seulement en angleterre
et pourquoi le maroc n'est pas la france
ou l'espagne
nous avons regardé en espagne mais les
vilains bord de mer sont chez nous on
veut avoir un bout de plage
et puis on a vu ça au maroc
on pense qu'il se passe vraiment quelque
chose au maroc ça vaut la peine d'aller
voir
[Musique]
nous sommes intéressés par la marina
parce que nous avons un bateau les
plages et les ports ont l'air très belle
sur les photos ce qui nous plaît
vraiment c'est la marine armée est ce
que vous êtes déjà allé au maroc avant
non c'est la première fois
[Musique]
donc vous allez acheter une maison dans
un pays que vous n'avez jamais visité
ouais
vingt minutes plus tard l'avion sur les
côtes du maroc et se pose sur l'aéroport
d'oujda la grande ville la plus proche
de saïdia il reste 50 km de route avant
d'atteindre le site
les anglais ont tous payé 3000 euros
pour réserver sur plan une ville 1 mais
c'est après cette visite qu'ils
décideront de signer ou non la promesse
d'achat définitive la possibilité aux
gens avant de signer le contrat de vente
c'était devenir boivent le site
donc s'ils ne veulent pas continuer
après la visite leurs 3000 euros
l'action en retourné sans aucun problème
vont ils ont cette facilité de venir
voir s'ils veulent beaucoup de gens ne
viennent pas voir du tout mais dans ce
cas là parce qu'une finale
ça que nous faisons ça tous les
vendredis avec les américains
[Musique]
trente minutes plus tard arrivée sur le
site évidemment ça ne ressemble pas aux
brochures qu'il consultait dans l'avion
arrivé sur la plage ils sont un peu
circonspecte
les anglais ne s'attendait pas à trouver
un chantier s'il peut avancer c'est
vraiment joli c'est sympa d'avoir la mer
un terrain de golf et ou à proximité
si m'inquiète c'est de savoir si ce sera
terminé à temps bien encore beaucoup à
faire encore aucun signe du terrain de
golf et même pas de pelouse mais
vraiment encore beaucoup à faire
eux disent qu'ils vont être prêts dans
18 mois mais ça va être limité
et pour corser le tout le beau temps
n'est pas au rendez vous oui la mer est
agitée d'habitude
l'eau est totalement bleu aujourd'hui il
ne fait pas beau donc ce n'est pas la
plus jolie couleur
d'habitude ce n'est pas le gris que vous
voyez aujourd'hui normalement quand les
gens arrivent ici ils font juste
waouh l'eau est totalement bleu ils le
restent à découvrir enfin l'emplacement
de leur ville à la plage pilotes
les villas seront construites ici sur ce
terrain à 500 mètres de la mer seulement
pour l'instant il n'y a rien à voir là
les fondations ne sont pas encore
commencé les clients sont dubitatifs et
hôtels et samba des femmes battues c'est
de l'argent que nous avons eu du mal à
gagner nous ne voulons pas le gaspiller
donc on va être très attentif on va
beaucoup puis réfléchit donc vous n'êtes
pas prêt à signer maintenant un pas
maintenant non on verra
et pour simon chaque client qui
n'achètent pas ces 500 euros de perdus
le prix du billet d'avion mais ça fait
partie du jeu on amène des gens toutes
les semaines
des fois y'a les clients n'y a pas de
clients il ya des agents ça dépend c'est
un coup que notation simon a eu raison
de ne pas s'inquiéter
une semaine plus tard les deux couple
d'anglais ont signé la promesse d'achat
deux villas à 400000 euros mais si
aujourd'hui tout le monde espère faire
fortune grâce à saïdia il y en a que
cela exaspère depuis trois ans un petit
groupe d'irréductibles s'opposent au
projet ce sont les écologistes de la
région
il accuse le gouvernement de bétonner le
littoral marocain
ils nous ont emmenés à 500 mètres du
site de saïdia et voilà à quoi
ressemblait cette plage il ya quatre ans
et ici il n'accepte toujours pas que le
promoteur espagnol est arraché toute la
végétation qui retenaient les dunes du
site vous êtes ici maintenant en train
de filmer la dernière parcelle naturel
de paysages naturels
la plage a à mon fils à l'aréa qui
stabiliser la place n'existe plus mais
tâchez dire on pourrait vous dire que
vous êtes contre le développement que
vous êtes rétrogradé qu'en fait tu
voulais pas de progrès si on entend par
des voleurs et or a personnellement je
suis contre la bétonisation il doit j'ai
moi une plage comme ça qui est ouvert au
public à monsieur tout le monde
woerth il ya de l'eau ya du sable il ya
de la verdure et il ya le ciel là bas
quand on va se déplacer
j'ai pas désert et bien il ya plus de
verdure il ya plus des siennes ça y est
c'est colmater ces sept kilomètres d'une
muraille de béton qui couvre maintenant
le y avait pas cette fraîcheur que vous
sentez maintenant
les écologistes sont aujourd'hui les
seuls à s'opposer ouvertement au projet
de saïdia la beauté du paysage et le
respect des sites naturels pour les
autorités locales il y à d'autres
priorités
farid chourak et responsable du centre
d'investissement de la région le maroc
n'est absolument pas en train de brader
son littoral faut pouvoir avoir de la
croissance et point c'est tout non on
s'inscrit aussi dans un développement
durable c'est celui qui permet de
préserver les avais dans les choses que
nous avons il est aussi un deuxième
souci auquel je les invite aussi
réfléchir nos amis écologistes c'est de
pouvoir faire cet arbitrage entre les
emplois et le reste
selon les autorités marocaines saïdia
devrait entraîner la création de 50
mille emplois directs ou indirects
un argument décisif dans une région où
le chômage touche 30% de la population
d'ici trois ans cinq autres villes vont
sortir de terre
objectif du gouvernement passer de six à
dix millions de touristes en 2010
[Musique]
et
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]